bill has 198
marbles in his collection he then buys
another 44. a year later he decides that
he has had enough of marbles and decides
to split them as evenly as possible
between the other 31 students in his
math class
roughly
how many marbles will each of his
classmates get and the fact that we have
the word roughly here means we don't
need to get the exact answer if it said
roughly or estimate how many marbles
each of his classmates will get that
says hey we maybe we can round these
numbers a little bit to make our
calculations a little bit easier so
let's give a go at that so he had he
starts with 198 marbles well let's round
everything to the nearest 10 and maybe
that'll simplify things so 198 if we
were to round to the nearest 10 well
we'd want to look at the ones place the
ones place we have an eight
if you have a ones place that's five or
greater then you're going to round up if
you're going to round to the nearest 10.
so if you round the nearest 10 if you
round up if from 198 is actually 200
we'll just go up to 200 that's also the
nearest hundred so this is approximately
equal to
200 and this little squiggly equal sign
that means roughly equal to or
approximately equal to
and so this is what he starts off with
then he buys another 44
44 is approximately equal to if we round
to the nearest 10 we look at our ones
place it's less than 5 so we're going to
round to the 10 below 44. the 10 below
44
is
40. if we go to the nearest 10 going
down we get 240. so how many total
marbles did he have before he
distributes them well if we take our
rough two if we take our two rough
estimates and if we add them 200 plus 40
he has roughly
240 marbles before he distributes them
now how many students is he going to
distribute them between
well there's a total of 31 students
there's 31 students but once again let's
round this if we round this to the
nearest 10 we're gonna round down
because our ones place has a one in it
it's less than five so we're going to
round to the 10 below 31 so that is
going to be
30.
so if you have roughly 240 marbles and
you're going to distribute them amongst
roughly 30 folks then how many are each
of them going to get well each of them
are going to get 240 divided by
divided by 30. once again this is just a
rough estimate roughly 240 marbles
divided by 30 folks well what's 240
divided by divided by 30.
well if we say that this is equal to if
we say that this is equal to the marbles
per student so let's say that this is m
m for marbles per student
this is another way of saying that m
times 30 m times 30
is equal to 240 or that 240 is equal to
m times 30. let me write it that way so
that's the same thing as saying that 240
is equal to m
times 30 where m is what we're trying to
figure out the the rough number of
marbles per student so let's think about
what m is and there's a bunch of ways we
could do it we could just look at our
multiples of 30. so 30 60
90 notice this is very similar to taking
multiples of three but we just have a
zero now the the the
the multiples of three are now in the
tens place and now we have a zero in the
ones place 90
120 which is just a 12 with a zero
150
180
180 210
240. so what is this is 30 times 1 2 3 4
5 6 7
8. so we know that 240 is equal to 30
times 8 so we could write
240
is equal to and 30 times 8 is the same
thing as 8 times 30 is equal to
8
times 30
is equal to 8 times 30 or another way we
could say is what the number of marbles
on each of his friends is going to get
is roughly 8. so this is going to be
this is going to be eight so each of his
classmates is going to get roughly
roughly eight marbles once again this is
an estimate it's not an exact answer
now you might have tried to get a
slightly more precise answer if you want
if you didn't want to round 198 and 44
you could have just added the two 8 plus
4
is 12
and then 1 plus 9 plus 4 is 14
1 plus 1 is 2. so the exact number of
marbles he had was 242 which is pretty
close to 240. so 240 was a good
approximation and then when you divide
that by dividing it by 31 is a bit of a
pain and luckily we can just estimate so
we divided by 30 and we got eight and
this is another kind of aside here
notice
notice 24
24 divided by three is equal to eight
and if you if you divide 240
240 divided by 30 this is also this is
also equal to 8. so if you divide
something 10 times as large by something
10 times as large you're still going to
get the same value but either way
each of his classmates are going to get
roughly eight marbles